[Musique]
puis sur bfm ils ont encore pris
l'antenne cette heure trop tôt avant le
débat ils ont envoyé leur monsieur
meuble c'est le gars qui décrit tout ce
qu'ils voient pour gagner du temps et
moi c'est intéressant qui vont donc
faire ce petit parcours je vais vous
amener c'est par ce couloir ans que vous
en rêvez les 11 candidats ici les onze
pupitre pour les onze candidats avec ses
caméras pour ne rien rater de ce débat
benoît hamon c'est la première que l'on
trouve le jeu de catch la télé un canapé
un espace maquillage et ses chaises et
bien c'est le c'est le public qui sera
assis ici même jour que tout est vrai en
plus il s'est pas arrêté là il a
continué à nous faire visiter les
backstage vous avez vous voyez bien
et voici un censeur c'est cet ascenseur
qu'utiliseront les candidats pour
rejoindre leur loge
il faudra bien sûr qu'ils appuient sur
le bouton monter le studio est
entièrement éclairé à l'aide de spots du
23 ans perd chacun des candidats est
équipé d'un convecteur électrique marche
on a chaud arrêt on a moins chaud en cas
d'incendié
le patient a également écouté
d'extincteurs extincteur numéro trois en
un instant je vous montrerai de
catherine un peu plus loin et voici des
piles
ceci est une plante verte voici un plot
blanc ceci est un nombril et ceci est un
mot de la chaîne qui me demande de
fermer ma gueule
[Musique]
c'est vrai renchérit merci pour ton
retour